what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interviews YouTube channel for
an in-person interview with the one and
only Diego Luna congratulations CCA
nominee yeah yeah I'm very happy about
that
congratulations well deserved and
congratulations on the show overall I
was just telling you this before we
started rolling but oh my you guys have
created something very special here
thank you thank you it's it's been a
journey it's been a beautiful Journey
very intense you know and uh we've been
learning uh on the way you know because
we are dealing with a format that is
different from everything else I've done
before 12 episodes it's uh it's
it's a lot of work you know it's a lot
of story it's so many characters uh the
the production is huge and I mean just
of shooting right now we're shooting the
second season and uh
It's My Life till August you know of
shooting just shooting then the whole
post-production process starts so it's
it's quite a journey that shooting will
be mixed with some season one
celebrating you have quite the next
couple of weeks and months ahead of you
I'm very excited about that also just
randomly bringing up the amount of story
that this covers I think that was one of
the most impressive elements of the show
to me was that you had so many key
characters in the mix I feel like it's
it isn't as likely that they come
together as well as they do and those
narratives wind up crossing over with a
great purpose like they do in this show
so that was probably one of the most
impressive things yeah it's it's
Tony Gilroy his vision is just
it's he's so ambitious you know and he
takes so much time and he delivers and
it's and and
every character has a meaning has a
reason has a journey and he pays
attention to to all the detail uh you
know uh there's there's no characters
there just because we need to trigger
something there's there's a there's an
important reason you know we are talking
about uh we are talking about the
Journey of someone that decides to give
everything for the costs you know what
has to happen in the life of someone and
what events he has to witness what
people he has to meet he has answered
all those questions you know uh Tony and
and I just feel really proud to be part
of such a rich show you know we have 12
episodes of 40 something minutes uh and
uh and I don't think we wasted any any
time you know basically not a single
second very ambitious and I am so
impressed by how well you pulled it off
going back to the beginning briefly on
this so I know it was really important
to you to reveal the truth behind the
Rogue one line I've been in this fight
since I was six years old what would you
say is the biggest difference but also
the biggest similarity in the backstory
you built when delivering that line on
Rogue one versus what it turned out to
be in the show I think in terms of the
the context of the character I I was
I was pretty much there you know I think
the story of Tony is something that
connects easily with what I had in mind
but it's it's more about the characters
he meets in the in in the journey uh
where I was impressed by what Tony
wanted to tell you know the the the
characters he meets Lutheran Kino uh the
relation with Marva you know that is
something so like Central in the
understanding of Cassian you know and
and I for me it wasn't like that when I
when I was getting ready for for rogue
one I had to create my own backstory uh
a backstory that no one cared about it
was just mine I mean in terms of like I
didn't have to get there with any other
actor my character was coming from
somewhere else you know he has this
accent that no one shares and he clearly
uh has left everything behind uh
therefore it was just the work you do as
an actor right that you have have to
understand why you're making the choices
you're making and create yourself some
background story but with Tony it was it
was so interesting to find out all these
role models that Cassian has you know
and uh and and the amount of sacrifice
around uh around the Rebellion you know
uh
it's quite it's quite interesting to see
uh so many characters
willing to
to leave everything behind for for a
reason they believe in you know it's
it's a beautiful story that reminds us
what we are capable of basically and uh
and it's through these characters that I
was like oh my God this is so rich and
so pertinent and so real even though we
are in this galaxy far far away these
characters could you know they feel
really close to to the world you and I
live in
they also feel very full that was
another thing that I was very impressed
by you have all these characters around
him and whether they get many episodes
of screen time or even or just in a
single episode there's something about
every single performance in this show
that makes everybody feel like a living
breathing person who had a significant
amount of History even where even though
we're not exposed to all that history in
the actual script yeah well it's exactly
that I mean there's a lot we don't tell
you here but we need you to feel it you
know we need you to understand it just
by witnessing a moment of of real
Behavior you know the the the
there was a constant reminder uh things
have to be real we have we have to
forget that we're in a galaxy far far
away this has to this has to be
happening you know and uh and the the
work was done not just by the amazing uh
cast that that is in the show but also
by the but the production design and the
costumes and the the makeups and and
everything had to be grounded you know
and we all need needed to know the story
behind uh this is something we we
we spend a lot of time doing you know
having so many conversations before
getting on Set uh
asking all the questions you had to ask
because the moment on said you had to
and you had to know what you're doing
there why you were there why you're
wearing this what is the purpose of of a
room like this why is this microphone
and not another one you know that kind
of thing and um so we all built this
this world and these characters uh
in the teamwork you know where directors
got behind also uh
these decisions it's
sometimes there's a feeling when you are
doing science fiction that you can get
away with things you know that who cares
you know the character happens to be
here in this process that wasn't the
case you know in this process if you
didn't have an answer uh you were not
doing your job you know and and that
applied for everyone on set not just
actors so we all had an opportunity to
interact with Tony and the directors and
uh and the production designer
and we were we had the chance to yeah to
to chat and to and to ask what needed to
be asked and I think you can tell that
everyone knows what they're doing in
this show you know there's not a single
moment where you go like well that
person
he happened to be there and you know the
jacket happened to fit him that that
wasn't the case here everyone everyone
went through a process of casting it was
very rigorous you know we saw people two
three times before
uh before they they even got the jobs
and uh
and all that work I think
it's there it's behind the series you
know what is an example of a seemingly
small detail that you had to know the
answer behind or the reasoning behind
that viewers might not expect you to
have to have had to look into to that
extent
foreign
I don't know I don't know if I'm gonna
be able to tell you one specific thing
but what I'll tell you something I do
and I like doing is going to sets before
we're shooting right so you arrive to a
place where you're supposed to interact
with this office as as or this set sorry
as if you had done hundreds of
interviews here therefore you can not
arrive in the morning and find out where
you're going to be sitting down so I
would go the day before at least if not
if not weeks before to interact with the
staff to find out what was what's going
to be behind me and why what is the
reason for it you know for this watch to
be like I can explain none of this to
you but they work very hard and I'm I'm
grateful we get to be here I don't know
like I wanted to understand everything
you know and I would ask the questions
and I would have this this these
sessions with Luke or our production
designer on set you know to to be
introduced to my house or to be
introduced to uh the little you know you
know where he sleeps you know the the
um
there's a he has the starpath unit in a
in a shelter in the in the how do you
[ __ ] sorry my my English is not it's not
in in the best shape now uh anyway
there's a there's a shelf where I bring
the starpath unit out of you know and I
we came up with the idea of hitting it
twice and then the thing opens by itself
that's not written you know you arrive
with a production designer you go like
what's a cool way to open it in a way no
one else would know it's possible let's
do it this way and we came up with that
little thing and it's something very
specific and and thin it's a layer
that's there of authenticity uh and uh
which it would have been very simple to
arrive and open the Shelf bring the
thing out but no we came out with a
little trick that Cassian knows and does
uh that way you understand things are
safe if they're there you know stuff
like that it was uh
stuff we were doing every day you know
trying to find and more and more layers
to enrich the the scenes we had those
types of little details is what makes a
person feel real and whole it's making
me think I was just talking to Guillermo
del Toro for his stop-motion Pinocchio
movie and they they purposely put in
examples of you know characters making
mistakes like not doing something
fluidly like tying your shoe in a way
that isn't like Pitch Perfect the perf
the first time they did it and that's
that's part of the reason why they feel
like living breathing human beings even
though they're movie characters that we
only spend two hours with you know in
the the relation for example with um
with the Droid uh that is something also
we were building you know and I was
thinking a lot about that first TV I had
in my house that the image would go like
it's more than you had to heat it then
and it would feel the screen again these
very old TVs I mean obviously people
don't understand these days that there
was something before the flat tvs that
we used to to to see at home uh but it
was this gigantic TV for a tiny screen
like this and I remember hitting that
thing five ten times a day you know uh
for the thing to actually work uh and I
I love the the idea that
this was probably the most precious
thing in my house these very old black
and white TV that I could have in my own
room and uh and my relation was this
hitting the thing to let her know I
needed her right
hitting the the objects so so many times
a day to make sure we could have a
we could communicate so I said like
let's bring I mean somehow that has to
work with with B2 you know B2 needs some
more respect in season two I feel like
like he's so respected he needs like
even more like he just went through so
much so much this season it broke my
heart and everyone in this
[Music]
it's what what this show is great about
like
at the end you do understand why A
revolution is needed you know the life
of these people
my God what they go through on these 12
episodes you know
you understand why the need for change
right
um
but I got all serious now and somewhere
else uh B2 I think B2 is is is in great
hands and everyone everyone loves him
and
I I love the the the way that Droid
relates with the community and the town
you know Ferris is his place you know
and you see him crossing the Avenue in
the morning uh going from from east to
west
um he he's he's a special
uh collaborator
to work with you know there's a it's a
big team behind me too uh but it's all
happening it's all there and it's
beautiful uh we we worked really hard in
making sure the sound was coming out of
the Droid you know so even though you're
interacting with the
you're interacting with a
yeah a natural Droid that is actually
talking to you there's a great actor uh
just next door but the sound comes out
of the Droid you know and uh there's
moments where you forget that there's
four people working on making that thing
be alive you know suddenly it's there
and you are interacting with the real
thing and you can have a
personal connection it's
it's a it's a beautiful
it's a beautiful friendship that one you
know it's
it's quite special I think it's what in
a way it's a little bit what we
wish our dogs were no like that's why
I'm partial to droids I'm a big pet
lover so there's there's something about
that kind of quality and loyalty that
I've seen in certain droids and Star
Wars that always get to my heart Cassian
talks to to be too like you can talk to
your dog imagine one day your dog
answers back that is the relation they
have you know where it's uh but but he
behaves like a dog he's he's always
gonna do whatever Cassian says you know
but he's gonna let him know he he thinks
uh it's wrong
that doesn't mean he will I mean he will
question Cassian all the time but he
will do exactly what he's been told and
uh and there is like a a complexity in
that relation that I love you know and
even that is complex in our show you
know even that that could be just like a
simple
lovely story to to see it's complex and
sometimes it's quite unfair with with B2
and uh and the poor Droid dates on on
behaving or not on doing what cousin
says or not there's just certain things
that b wants that someone says no you
can't do it or can't have it I'm like
just give the Droid What It Wants yes
yes
I have so expressive also in the design
you know the sign of the Droid is it's a
it's very smart because it's very simple
but it has it has a way to receive the
information and and be affected with a
very simple kind of mechanics you know
and and very very very few movements uh
say so much it's a quite a piece of
design one of many elements of the show
I'm very impressed by I have a couple of
very specific complex moments that I
want to touch on here I feel like
everybody out there knows this at this
point but you should have watched Andor
by now just in case you didn't go watch
it push pause on this video and then
come back for the rest of the
conversation which will be loaded with
spoilers this is your one and only
warning all right my first very specific
question for you
when you're playing the moment where
you're having the conversation with
Skeen and he's revealing that he's
willing to take the credits and run what
has to be going through andor's mind to
justify that split-second decision to
shoot him on the spot
it's interesting because I think I think
[Music]
um
I would say he just went through the
first time of an actual teamwork like in
terms of trusting others with your life
you know he goes through that with this
team
and when he realizes he should have not
trust this person you know uh how
dangerous someone you can't trust can be
when you're trying to put together uh or
organize something in terms of
what you can do as Community you know uh
basically
everyone else is to to be trusted there
and uh and having one one leak is you
know uh is is very dangerous you know he
understands
he understands how much yeah
um
trust and and
how do you say because trust I mean I'm
looking for the word in Spanish is is
called fianza which is sounds a little
more robust than trust uh I like it I
mean I don't know we'll we'll have to
look for the translation you like trust
Faith confidence okay Faith is involved
like you have to believe yeah in the
person next to you not just that you can
trust them but but that you can that
they will deliver
and uh and he realizes that he's been
he's been next to someone that would
would not put his hand there for him you
know
and it's it's interesting why why or how
fast uh the character you know makes
choices that are gonna Define everything
you know I mean that's how the season
starts basically with him uh finding out
he he has to kill this person you know
and uh
and this is the second time that it
happens and it tells you uh that he's no
he's not a he's not afraid or scared of
of
making a complicated Choice like that
and uh he's taking care of the whole
team he's taking care of hair where he's
taking you know he he doesn't he doesn't
know and I mean we are okay spoiling
spoilers spoilers are fair game right
now
um he doesn't know namik is it's gone
you know and he's protecting them he's
protecting them he's feeling part of a
team for the first time so I think I
took five minutes and the answer is this
last thing I just said you can erase all
the other crappies because it's
basically yeah he's he's protecting a
team for the first time a team he's
about to to leave behind
right but uh but but it's that hint of
like oh I'm part of something and I have
to protect them the way you describe it
it's like the perfect baby step in his
evolution in terms of like losing faith
in one member of the team but without
letting him lose faith in the team
overall and the surviving members yeah
yeah yeah
and uh
and he
I I I like a lot about this character
that
it's enough with the
like he he
he's someone capable of forgiving
himself you know which is something that
makes people different you know we all
we all make mistakes but if you give
yourself a second chance that that says
that you're someone special you know
this guy is like that he's not gonna
then go talk to someone say like Luke
skin was trying to do this he he makes
the choice himself in a second
and uh and he moves on you know and uh
he he is
like the conversation with himself is
open you know he's uh honest to himself
I like that about this this man you know
I know
getting into the next big set piece I
was wondering does the name Keith have
meaning to him because he takes the name
Clem because it's his late father's name
but what about Keith in particular
because that connection was making me
think that there had to be meaning to
that as well the the
okay I I I let me think if I can if I
can answer that one
I I was it took me a while to be able to
pronounce that name uh uh Keith gargoyle
um
no
no no nothing that can be that you can
connect with what you've seen so far
okay I'll take that here's a here's a
theory type question for you it's just
something that I've been thinking about
since uh watching episode 10. yeah let's
say Andor did not get pushed off the
platform into the water after he was
told that um oh my God the name is
escaping me now Andy sharks this
character uh Kino Kino after Aquino
tells him he can't swim if Andor hadn't
been pushed into the water there do you
think he would have made an effort to
help him swim to safety
do you do you have any doubt
like my God then I've done I've done
terrible my job is not done
do you you think you think he would have
been like oh I'm so sorry I don't doubt
I don't doubt and or I doubt the
situation and how it all would have
progressed and turned I've tried
everything okay I feel everything I feel
like my Doubt's more and more in Kino
like he would have insisted on staying
and like making sure everybody got off
question you know to save him uh there's
yeah I mean we didn't shoot any any
alternative endings but I already
started thinking about so many uh I
think probably if he hadn't been pushed
uh Rogue one would
would have not been there so
that's that's the other thing that isn't
a doubting character that he at that
point in the show has a better
understanding of of like the larger
Mission and what's at stake and he might
have had to just go to you know I'll
tell you this
it's not I mean Kino doesn't find out he
doesn't swim just before jumping right
Kino doesn't say it because of a reason
you know I think these two know each
other so well in that moment
that Kino knows if if Cassian would have
known
he would change the plan and try to come
up with another idea you know but not
jumping uh to the open Waters uh and I
think Kino knows and I think you and I
you should know if you're saying you
love the show and you've seen the whole
show
you should know I mean by this moment
this guy is uh he's he's a team worker
you know he's uh he commits not just to
ideas but to people
and I think I think that's the big big
lesson he gets in in prison you know uh
that you were as strong as
as the the connection with your team is
you know that's where your strength is
in that
capacity we have you know to
think bigger than just ourselves and I
think for for
I mean the way cousin could have grabbed
the microphone and started giving the
speech when he thinks Kino is not
delivering but he wants to see Kino the
liver I love that beat you know he wants
to see Kino become that voice and uh and
he takes him there I think one thing
that happens in that episode that is
really that is crucial for me uh is that
cassin understands he can be a leader
you know he can change someone he can he
can help Kino transition to become that
person you know
uh and I I don't think he he would have
accept uh that Kino had to be sacrificed
you know for this to happen I think deep
down I'm also just looking for an excuse
for Andy Circus to come back and for
Kino to be alive and play a part in the
mission going forward
well I mean if we if we are
did you see what happened to Kino
yes what
well that's a good way to phrase it I
should learn learn my lesson after years
and years of covering I'm a horror movie
lover too and the rule is if you don't
see someone dead dead dead
okay yeah all right all right I did I I
didn't see what happened you know I just
seeing is pushed and uh and the camera
goes with them
so I I wonder what happened like the
point you raise here
you just bring up the fact that in that
moment Cassian realizes he can be a
leader and he evolves quite a bit over
the course of season one I know you're
shooting season two so it's a tricky
thing to answer but what is a new asset
that Andor gains in season one that
you're eager to see audiences
your eager for audiences to see him use
in season two but also what is the next
weakness on his list that he needs to
overcome to be the leader that he
ultimately needs to be
weaknesses you I mean weaknesses you you
get to see even in Rogue one it's that
that road never ends no it's perfect you
never even reach that you don't get
there you know
um but uh
I think I think what happens also after
prison and uh and in the next episodes
uh is that he understands really what's
what what he's fighting against you know
uh he understands the the need of a
revolution because he understands what
what oppression means you know basically
and uh
and how little Freedom he has and how
unfair the world he live he lives in is
so
uh but there's still so much for him to
learn you know uh in terms of
working
as a as a team you know working uh
how do you say he says so I mean I think
in the in the first season we see him
trying to survive
and uh which is not necessarily
being part of something you know it's
reacting to it
um but uh but now yeah he has to learn a
lot from Lutheran and from others
from other experiences other events
in order to to be that person we meet in
Rogue one you know he
the the
responsibility he he's
he takes on the beginning of Row one is
huge
imagine what has to happen for someone
to say
he's the right person to do it you know
Casino should
be the the
it's gonna be the person we're gonna
trust with this
there's a lot for him to uh you know to
discover and uh and and a big
transformation to come uh he's really
far from that the one of episode 12 it's
so far from that you know but the spark
is there there's an Awakening and it has
happened now we need to witness four
years of the life of this man oh and
I'll end with this question that builds
on that can you maybe like tease or
somewhat explain why it felt best to
have season one of the show focus on one
year through 12 episodes but then have
season two cover years two three four
and five leading up to Rogue one in
three episode blocks why did that serve
the story in his journey best
the I mean I I wish I had like a cool
answer for that but I don't like we
we didn't want this to end up being an
animated series you know and and I mean
I I am who I am and and Tony Gilroy is I
mean has to be the writer of this and we
cannot be doing this for 10 years
doing one season takes
oh yeah basically
the first season took like four years
the second will take a little less but
you have to think it has he has to write
12 episodes then we have to
go on pre-production that normally takes
like six to eight months you know to
build these places and and to start with
the whole process of Designing casting
then the execution is another seven
eight months and then
uh post-production starts and that's not
easy either
so it's a long journey each season takes
like three four years of of my life and
of Tony Gilroy's life so you you
obviously at the beginning we said like
it'll be great to do five seasons this
was before kovid you know long ago
but once we started and we
decided it was going to be this story
this way it was pretty clear that it
would have been impossible to do five
seasons of this so Tony came with this
amazing idea
because we were already breaking it in
blocks you know uh in in four blocks
four blocks of Three episodes that's how
we shoot
that's how we should uh
so each director uh gets three episodes
and shoots that as a movie in a way you
know
so Tony said like well if we're missing
four years and we have four episodes it
could be perfect because it's it's gonna
be like movies that would have a
beginning and an end you know each year
will have a beginning and an end and it
would be a chapter
three episodes
if you guys deem that the best possible
route I trust you I'm greedy and I want
to see you in this world forever I know
that's not possible
it's not because of us it's because of
Rogue one Rogue one said the the I mean
I I also have to look
close enough to Rogue one you know so
can you imagine me in 10 years
pretending to be the one I was 20 years
ago just impossible I mean sadly there's
no machines or CGI they can do you can
do anything what are you talking about
we have to rap I have so many more
questions I'm glad we get to talk again
later because then I can repurpose these
congratulations huge huge huge
congratulations on this very special
show and also your CCA nomination which
is very well deserved oh thank you very
much